بين كل المناورات المشتركه التي اجريت
خلال الاسابيع الماضيه تعتبر هذه الاكثر
دراماتيكيه خلال السنوات الخمس الاخيره
كما انها واحده من اكثر العروض اثاره
للجدل فهي تظهر استعداد كوريا الجنوبيه
لاي غزو من طرف جارتها الشماليه مئات من
عناصر المارينز الكوريين الجنوبيين
والامريكيين انتشروا على الشاطئ لاختبار
القدرات الدفاعيه لدى الحلفاء هنا يقولون
انها محاكاه لهجوم مضاد من عدو قد يهاجم
في اي لحظه
هذا التمرين مخصص للدفاع عن شبه الجزيره
الكوريه هو مهم بالنسبه لنا وبالنسبه
لاستقرار المنطقه ككل
كوريا الشماليه ردت على هذه المناورات
باطلاق عدد من الصواريخ الباليستيه في
الايام والاسابيع الماضيه كما اجرت
تمرينات تحاكي مهاجمه الجنوب وحلفائه حرصت
على استعراض اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه ونشر ذلك
في اجهزه الاعلام الرسميه بحضور الرئيس
الكوري الشمالي كيم جونغ اون